hello and welcome to the autumn 2011
edition of Rochford district matters the
information paper for the people of
Rochford district in this edition our
article was on the 2011 Sports Awards
NHS helped to choose well changes to
parking charges the low-carbon business
program and much more but we're going to
start with details of the forthcoming
arc trail
between the 22nd and 29th of October the
historic market town of Rochford will
host a wide range of artists and art
workshops in shops businesses cafes and
public spaces discover temporary art
exhibitions at every turn from
established artists emerging talent and
local community groups displaying
ceramics photographs painting textiles
sculpture and contemporary crafts 65
artists will be exhibit in artworks in
the 34 venues around the town the trail
launches on Saturday October the 22nd
with a huge day of arts activities for
everyone to enjoy including pavement
chalking face painting and free
caricatures so visit the website www k
forward slash art trail for the latest
updates and a suggested route to visit
all artists and venues in the rockville
art trail follow the venue numbers in
sequence start at venue one in back lane
car park and end at venue 32 the
historic Rochford hall and the Rochford
hundred golf club
council receptions in rochford and
rayleigh now have new automatic kiosks
installed to try to make payment
facilities quicker and easier to use the
kiosks have these benefits easy to use
touchscreen cash and card transactions
are allocated to your account invoice on
the same day they give change you can
pay by credit and debit card they have
the latest coin and note fraud detection
they give you fully itemized receipts
previously the only way to pay by debit
or credit card was to use the council's
online system or our call center already
we have seen more than 250 transactions
come through the kiosks on card of until
recently checks had to be put through
machines but following your feedback
this is no longer required as long as
customers don't require a receipt our
reception staff are fully trained and
can help you if you have any questions
require tech envelopes or just need a
hand using the new kiosks for the first
time
rochford and rayleigh Citizens Advice
Bureau is a valuable resource to the
local community for any residents who
need advice on debt benefits housing
employment and many more areas of daily
living if you're a resident in the
district and need advice on any of these
issues then one of nearly 70 volunteers
that the advice bureau are on hand to
help each week initial assessments are
also available on the phone 0844 for
double 70 80 8 or you can visit www k
for initial information on a variety of
aspects of daily living some clients
problems are complex and it's necessary
for the bureau to refer them on to
specialist advisors in addition to an
in-house specialist rajput and rayleigh
Citizens Advice Bureau has access to
legal aid specialists in debt housing
employment and benefits for people who
meet the qualifying criteria the current
opening hours for initial assessments
are as follows in the rockford office
which is back lane rockford SS 41 a why
on tuesday between 10 and 2 and on
thursday between ten and two at the
rayleigh office which is the civic sweet
hockey road rayleigh SS 680 be there
open from ten a.m. to two p.m. on
mondays thursdays and fridays
fraley Rochford a district association
for voluntary service or raft has a wide
range of support on offer across the
community in the Rockford district Raz
is once again running their popular
laptop courses which aims to help
over-50s learn computing skills in a
relaxed atmosphere laptop can help you
with a beginners computer course home
visits and a computer club all in a
relaxed atmosphere among the skills the
course teaches are how to visit websites
that you have seen on television how to
send emails with photos attached how to
transfer photos from cameras to
computers and print them out and learn
about internet shopping so if you are
over 50 and baffled by computers contact
revs on 01 268 double 727 96 or email
raft and that's our ra vs a travs org
dot uk'
you can help stamp out scams and fraud
by taking part in a Citizens Advice
Bureau CA B survey have you been scammed
or do you want to see action to stamp
out common fraud and scams if so
rochford and rayleigh citizens advice
bureau wants to enlist your help in its
campaign to foil scammers offering dodgy
deals that cause people billions of
pounds every year the cab is urging
people to take part in a quick and
simple anonymous online survey to find
out what scammers are up to locally and
which scans local people most want to
see action against the survey highlights
10 corn scans ranging from bogus job ad
to phantom flats and fake lottery wins
it also asks about scams that trade on
cold calling and ask for upfront fees
for goods and services that fail to
materialize including loans and debt
management building work and event
tickets some fraudsters even managed to
extract bank card details from the
people they target and go on to help
themselves to money from their accounts
for more information and to take part in
the survey go to ww it isn't advice go
guk forward slash campaigns
the 2011 rochford district sports garla
award ceremony is set to take place at
the mill arts & Events Center on
Thursday October the 13th now in its
fourth year the event has seen many
deserving sports contenders and clubs
nominated and recognized for their
achievements the guest of honor for this
year's awards sponsored by virgin active
will be badminton superstar Gail ms nbe
Gail has along with partner nathan
robertson be number one in the world at
mixed doubles all lincoln champion
commonwealth gold medalist and olympic
silver medalist these are the categories
sports personality of the year sponsored
by Wells legal solicitors and wells
legal homes disability sports
personality of the year sponsored by
waters and Stanton PLC young sports
personality of the year sponsored by
southend united community and
educational trust sports club of the
year sponsored by fountains services to
sport sponsored by the co-operative
funeralcare and rockford 2012 respect
award sponsored by mothers scrubbers to
previous sports award winners are also
part of star at my local an exciting
initiative aimed at helping them to
continue to excel at the highest level
businesses that are part of the shop at
my local scheme had the opportunity to
support and sponsor sailing champion
Lucy Hodges and badminton star Rebecca
Terry the current Rochford District
sports personality of the year Lucy won
gold both the 2010 blind Nationals and
ifds blind match racing international
championships Rebecca is the Rockford
district and Essex young sports
personality of the year and one of the
youngest players to represent Essex at
senior level local sports injury clinic
sports therapy and rehabilitation also
st AR has joined the growing number of
rockford district based businesses who
have joined
at my local st AR join active Rockford
Wells legal solicitors and wells legal
homes also sports award sponsors and DB
training in sport in supporting Lucy and
Rebecca star at my local is run by
Rochford District Council's leisure team
shop at my local and active Rochford if
you have any queries about either the
sports award or want to find out more
about star at my local pull the leisure
team on 0 1 702 31 8 121 further
information and biographies on all
sponsors including apprenticeship
opportunities with DB training at
wweshop.com forward slash star at my
local
the 50th wedding has recently taken
place at the rayleigh windmill and to
celebrate the council has put together a
special offer the next ten civil
ceremonies to be booked at the winner
will receive a twenty-five percent
discount and terms and conditions apply
the rayleigh where mill has become
immensely popular as a wedding venue
since it became licensed for civil
weddings civil partnerships naming
ceremonies and renewal of vows if you
are interested and wish to arrange a
viewing or to discuss your specific
requirements please contact Rochford
district council on 0 1 702 318 120 or 0
1 702 546 366 extension 3619
are you single under 35 and claiming
housing benefit or thinking of claiming
if the answer is yes then the jasus to
the way benefit will be calculated from
January 2012 could affect you from the
first of January 2012 housing benefit
will be reduced single people under the
age of 35 who do not live with any
children the maximum amount we will be
able to pay will be the local housing
allowance rate for a room in shared
accommodation the change will affect
single people between the ages of 25 and
34 people living in privately rented
accommodation excluding Housing
Association properties people who claim
after the first of January 2012 existing
customers who change address after the
first of January 2012 existing customers
when they have their annual rent review
after the first of January 2012 and
existing customers whose payment
protection ends after the first of
January 2012 there will be some people
who are protected including people who
qualify for a severe disability premium
in their calculation as the local
housing allowance for it to set every
month we do not know the rate for
January 2012 as a guide the one-bedroom
rate for September 2011 is 110 pounds 77
pence per week and the rate for shared
accommodation is 65 pound per week if
you're currently getting housing benefit
and think you may be affected we will be
writing to you shortly with more
information
since the first of april 2011 if you or
your partner has needed regular
overnight care and support you may well
have been entitled to more housing
benefit if a carer or team of carers
needs to regularly stay overnight and
you have a bedroom set aside for them to
use we can now take this into account in
working out how much you're entitled to
this means that a couple can now get
housing benefit for a two bedroom
property if one of them needs regular
overnight care and they live in a
two-bedroom or larger home to qualify
for this extra benefit you need to be
able to answer yes to all the following
questions do you live in a privately
rented home not including one rented
from a housing association do you or
your partner receive attendance
allowance or the middle or highest rate
of disability living allowance or can
you prove that overnight care is needed
have you actually arranged for care to
be provided by someone or a team of
people and they do not usually occupy
their from your property as their home
does this person or people regularly
stay overnight to provide this care and
do you have an extra bedroom which they
use when they're staying we'll need to
see proof that overnight care is needed
such as a doctor's letter will also need
to see a proof that the care is actually
being given if you think you may be
entitled to this extra benefit please
don't hesitate contact us immediately